madame la ministre lundi matin la france
la région kitan la département de la
haute garonne et particulièrement la
ville du lherm se sont réveillés sur le
choc
je souhaite d'abord apporter tout mon
soutien et ma compassion aux familles
endeuillées
ce que redoutait toutes les personnes
concernées par la dépendance et par
l'accueil réservé à nos aînés donnée de
se produire une crise sanitaire majeure
dans un ehpad une situation dramatique
avec le décès dans la nuit de cinq
pensionnaires et l'hospitalisation d'une
quinzaine de personnes
je ne reviendrai pas madame sur la
chaîne des dysfonctionnements qui a
conduit à ce désastre humain laissons la
justice faire son travail
vous insistez sur vous avait insisté sur
la volonté d'en comprendre les causes de
tirer les enseignements de ce tragique
événement mais madame la ministre nous
connaissons une partie des causes je
vous avertis c'est déjà au travers de ma
question orale tristement prémonitoire
du 12 février dernier le manque cruel
d'effectifs l'absence de revalorisation
des métiers du grand âge et de leur
rémunération
l'épuisement du personnel qui
régulièrement se mettant en grève tente
d'alerter sur les rythmes de travail et
dénoncent les conditions de prise en
charge de nos aînés
l'humain n'est plus au coeur de notre
mission d'accompagnement des personnes
âgées alors même que certains ehpad
génère des profits substantiels
madame la ministre ma double question
est simple le rapport libos sur le grand
âge et l'autonomie qui vient de vous
être me fait des propositions quand
seront elles mises en oeuvre avec quels
financements dédiés
l'urgence est là nous ne pouvons plus
attendre pour vous répondre la parole
comme adam
solidarité de la santé à la manière du
musée vous avez la parole ici
merci monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice micouleau merci évidemment de
me permettre de répondre sur un enjeu
majeur de société nous sommes tous
évidemment sensible à ce drame qui est
survenu dans la nuit de dimanche à lundi
dans un ehpad de votre département je me
suis rendu mardi pour rencontrer les
familles des victimes et les personnes
qui ont été hospitalisées
ainsi que le personnel qui était aussi
très choquée c'est un personnel très
engagé d'après les familles que j'ai pu
rencontrer
il s'agit évidemment d'un sujet sur
lequel une enquête est en cours une
instruction est en cours et j'attends
les résultats pour en tirer toutes les
conclusions et des mesures
supplémentaires si elles doivent être
prises seront prises dans les ehpad pour
assurer une chaîne alimentaire de très
grande qualité
il y a déjà des recommandations qui
existe qui ont été faites par la haute
autorité de santé en 2018
il faudra voir si celles ci ont été bien
suivies mais au-delà de cette ce drame
vous poser une question beaucoup plus
général qui inquiète tous les français
la prise en charge du grand âge et de la
perte d'autonomie nous sommes tous
concernés
il ya urgence à agir il ya trop
longtemps que nous reculons devant cet
obstacle parce que effectivement cela
nécessite une réorganisation complète du
secteur ainsi que des financements
conséquents pour améliorer la prise en
charge de nos aînés augmenter le nombre
de personnels auprès des personnes âgées
améliorer la prise en charge à domicile
revaloriser les métiers et tout cela
sont évidemment les pistes tracées par
le rapport de dominique libault qui m'a
été remis le 28 mars un groupe de
travail en urgence 20 ma portée des
conclusions sur la revalorisation des
métiers de la personne autour de la
personne âgée je pense que c'est
l'urgence aujourd'hui pour rendre ces
métiers de nouveau attractif et veiller
à la bientraitance des personnes âgées
mais au delà de ça nous remettrons
évidemment un projet de loi avant la fin
de l'année sur la base du rapport qui
m'a été remis avec 275 proposition de
dominique libault qui sont en cours de
cette instruction et qui vont être
travaillées avec les différentes parties
prenantes dans un espace de concertation
tout cela sera prêt avant la fin de
l'année je me suis engagé devant les
français je vous remercie
vous avez quelques secondes madame merci
madame la ministre nous serons très
attentifs aux résultats
sachez que nos aînés méritent mieux
qu'un abandon de la solidarité nationale
et nos personnels soignants mérite mieux
aussi comme désengagement de l'état
merci